two weeks in Europe is gonna be great
I'm just gonna enjoy my trip hang out
with MJ good really pretty therefore I
have value no no that's not what I meant
I'm messing with you that's really nice
so nice to finally meet you
spider-man here Nick Fury put some
clothes on let's go for a ride
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
[Music]
get gifts Parker but we have a job to do
you going to step up or not
we're all alone friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit in my really respective sub
dickwad hey everybody is Charlie there
are a whole bunch of sinister six Easter
eggs in the spider-man far from home
trailers and there's been a new report
from deadlines about returning
characters also notable sinister six
members so we got to break it down
there's a new round of that Amazon
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite spider-man villain on the video
so a lot of these sinister six Easter
eggs appear when the elementals appear
in the trailer I've talked about a few
of them before but there's even more
that we've uncovered since then so the
number of 463 appears on this license
plate when Nick Fury and Maria Hill are
fighting the Earth's elemental amazing
spider-man number four in 1963 is the
first appearance of Sandman a lot of you
made the connection that this giant
earth elemental looks very similar to
Sam Raimi's Sandman when he was in
giants and form
[Music]
when spider-man's - a group is running
from the giant fire looking elemental in
London on the bridge on the license
plate here over on the left you read
2865 SEP amazing spider-man number 28 in
September 1965 is the first appearance
of molten man there's an appearance of
another villain at a different carnival
location here in Prague Czech Republic
that looks like it could be either a
different elemental creature or it could
be the same fire elemental it's a little
bit hard to tell the way they cut the
trailers because MJ is looking at that
fire elemental close-up and what looks
like a different location from this big
bridge fight but then Peters group
checks into the JM DeMatteis Hotel de
Mateus longtime spider-man comic book
writer the spider-man story he's
probably most famous for writing is
Cravens last hunt notable original
sinister six member there's also been
sightings of a character on set people
think is the chameleon he's the
half-brother of Kraven the hunter and
chameleon debuted in amazing spider-man
number one remember that a lot of the
spider-man villains that Kevin Feige has
been pulling from in the comics are from
the earlier spider-man comics they're
the first 20 or so issues with a couple
of exceptions like molten man in hydro
man also big Easter Egg ASM 212 is
behind net here when they're going
through the Venice canals right before
we see spider-man try to fight this
giant water elemental remember he's
wearing the same plaid shirt here so
this boss fight probably happens
relatively close after you see this ASM
212 Easter egg in the background but
amazing spider-man number 212 is the
first appearance of hydro-man in the
comics when he's in the carnival fight
here - you can spot a license plate in
the background because a lot of these
Easter eggs come from license plates
anytime there's a number on something in
the background it usually winds up being
a comic book Easter Egg but it's too
blurry to actually read what the license
plate says the other really big sinister
6 Easter eggs are the dead line just
confirm Michael Keynes vulture would be
coming back for spider-man far from home
as well as Liz Allen now there are a
number of reasons why they could come
back there been a couple of notable
rumors the more credible ones that I've
seen is that when the movie picks up
he's still stuck in prison with the
scorpion other notable sinister six
member Matt Gargan scorpion who's also
rumored to have a cameo and far from
home but in taking Nick Fury's mission
to uncover the Miz
three of these supposed elementals
vulture somehow helps Peter either by
giving him information or contacts to
track down or help some uncover clues
about what the truth of Mysterio is
doing because it's very clearly
misleading Nick Fury in the world about
the true nature of the quote-unquote
elementals in his bid for all this good
press pumping him up to be the next big
thing like they say in the trailer he's
Iron Man and Thor all rolled into one
very clearly in homage to Mysterio's
debut story an amazing spider-man number
13 our next big sinister six Easter egg
where Mysterio wants to make himself
look like a hero so he dresses up in a
spider-man costume robbing banks in a
museum in New York City to make it look
like spider-man is committing a bunch of
crimes then in a bid to get good press
for himself goes to Jay Jones Jameson in
his Mysterio costume in pitches in his
own hero story claiming that he Mysterio
will capture the villainous spider-man
in a very public battle on a bridge see
where this is starting to get familiar
kind of like the bridge you see here in
the London trailer the real spider-man
Peter Parker totally kicks his ass and
Jay jonah Jameson still tries to smear
him in The Daily Bugle just because
that's their relationship but spider-man
far from home very clearly seems like
they're adapting a version of that
Mysterio fake-out hero story where Jake
Gyllenhaal's Mysterio is a skilled
visual effects artist idealizes the
Avengers in spider-man wants to be
famous and loved by everyone around the
world like they are but does the very
classic villainous thing where he seeks
fame and attention for selfish gain
because he's so narcissistic and
delusional he puts everyone's lives at
risk with these giant elementals almost
winds up killing a whole bunch of
innocent people in his bid to become the
next big Avenger level hero in the
public's eyes so in the comics what
happened is is that after spider-man
defeated Mysterio he got thrown in
prison he got so pissed off that that's
what led him to join the sinister six
under the patronage of Doctor Octopus
remember Doctor Octopus was kind of like
the leader of the original version of
the sinister six Norman Osborn Green
Goblin in the comics is mostly credited
with assembling the sinister 12 later in
the comics but yes there been a few
rumors about a Marvel version of Norman
Osborn at some point but if they really
are gonna do full-blown sinister 6 in
the third spider-man film they could
substitute any number of major
spider-man villains as the patron of
that team Mysterio
Osbourne or a new version of Doctor
Octopus everybody loves that original
version of the Sinister sakes but
remember what Kevin Feige said about
them doing new spider-man villains in
these movies
here's that clip of him talking about it
what's fun about this is the first time
spider-man's in the MCU and the first
time he's played by an actor who is the
age essentially that Spidey was in those
comics for so long and as Michael Keaton
does with the vulture we get to explore
villains that we haven't seen before and
Spidey has an amazing rose gallery so at
some point I think it might be
interesting to to revisit some of the
characters we've seen in films before
but right now we think there are a lot
of new ones that we haven't haven't
played with yet he did that interview
way back during spider-man homecoming
press a few years ago so they're gonna
do an MCU version of the sinister six
just expect them to substitute any
number of spider-man villains that they
may not have done before but he does say
that it would be fun to revisit some of
the villains that we've seen before
eventually but that was a couple years
ago so obviously he was talking more
about homecoming when he said that they
weren't gonna be redoing a lot of old
villains that they've already done
before when it comes to Norman Osborn is
a little too soon to say that anything
that they've done confirms that he's
going to be the next big thing yes he is
one of the few people canonically that
has the power the money the wealth to
buy the Avengers Tower from Tony Stark
because remember that sits right above
Grand Central Station that is probably
one of the most expensive buildings that
you could possibly buy in New York City
regardless of how much damage there was
after all these big battles in the
Avengers movie all the way through
avengers endgame you also have to assume
basic narrative structure that the stuff
that they tee up at the beginning of the
film will have an influence for what's
going on with Mysterio's arc later in
the film so what a coincidence that you
see spider-man getting all this good
press at the beginning of the trailer
helping the homeless people with the
help of Stark Industries Pepper Potts
and probably Tony Stark in the
background - everybody loves him he's
doing awesome he gets that high-five
from Aunt May so imagine somewhere
Mysterio is watching this on TV seeing
how much love spider-man is getting from
the public and he wants that love for
himself too but classic villain style
goes about getting it in a really
narcissistic way that being said
remember how they tied spider-man
homecoming all the way back to that
first Avengers film they do like to pay
off long-term Easter eggs so I wouldn't
be
- if they tie a lot of Mysterio's hopes
of becoming a big hero back to that
original Avengers movie as well most of
that I think is in service of creating
deep ties between the spider-man
franchise like all the 900-plus
characters that Sony has access to in
Peter Parker in the MCU movies the more
deeply those things are tied together
the more likely they are to continue
that relationship so let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
all these sinister six Easter eggs
during spider-man far from home and what
they might be doing in the background
leading up to that third spider-man film
the Superbowl is right around the corner
we're probably gonna get new Avengers
and game trailers maybe a new Captain
Marvel trailer I don't think we're gonna
get a new spider-man far from home
footage for a little while longer
because it's not coming out until summer
but if you have any special video
requests just leave them in the comments
below I'll name a new giveaway winner
when I post new Marvel click here to
rewatch the spider-man far from home
trailers a billion more times and click
here for my brand-new Game of Thrones
Season 8 trailer video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]